[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump is promising
to turn the nation's grief into action
when it comes to guns and he is
continuing to champion the idea of
arming teachers and faculty or some
trained personnel inside schools
he says bump stocks are quote gone no
matter what Congress does and the
president wants to give law enforcement
more latitude to take guns away from
high-risk people president Trump talked
to the nation's governors today at the
White House and said he would have gone
into that school and gone after the
Florida shooter
weapon or not chief White House
correspondent John Roberts starts us off
tonight from the North Lawn could even
jump Brett good evening president Trump
says he wants to change some of the laws
regarding gun ownership in the United
States that but that when it comes to
protecting the nation's schools the
President believes the cheapest and most
effective way to do it is to fight fire
with fire thank you very much in his
third major listening session president
Trump met with most of the nation's
governor's at the White House today
insisting the best way to deter school
shootings is to let killers know they
won't make it out alive
the bad guy has to understand that
there's a big price to pay when they
mess around with our students they have
to know they walk in they're going to
probably end up dead and if they know
they're gonna end up dead they're not
going into that school but on his
proposal to train and arm qualified
members of school faculty and staff
President Trump got pushback from
Washington's Democratic governor jay
Inslee I've listened to the first grade
teachers that don't want to be
pistol-packing first grade teachers I've
listened to law enforcement who have
said they don't want to have to train
teachers as law enforcement agencies
which takes about six months I just
suggest we need a little less tweeting
here a little more listening and let's
just take that off the table and move
forward it's not just Democrats who
oppose the idea Florida's Republican
Governor Rick Scott a staunch supporter
of President Trump says educators should
educate protecting schools is a job he
wants law enforcement to take on I'm not
waiting for the federal government we're
gonna invest five hundred million
dollars we're gonna have a significant
law enforcement presence
every public school in our state the
White House today wouldn't weigh in on
calls for Broward County Sheriff Scott
Israel to either step down or be
investigated but President Trump again
lashed out at deputy Scott Peterson and
possibly others for not rushing into the
school to take on the shooter saying he
would have done it differently they
weren't exactly Medal of Honor winners
all right the way they performed was
frankly disgusting I really believe you
don't know until you test it but I think
I really believe I'd run in there even
if I didn't have a weapon and I think
most of the people in this room would
have done that too president Trump also
promised that if Congress doesn't act
soon to ban so-called bump stocks used
by the shooter in the Las Vegas Massacre
he'll do it himself and while he hasn't
mentioned raising the minimum age for
buying a rifle for a few days the
president still supports the concept and
says he is prepared to go toe to toe
with the NRA over it don't worry about
the NRA they're on our side you guys
have for you are so afraid of the NRA
there's nothing to be afraid of and you
know what if then are with you we have
to fight him every once in a while
that's okay president Trump revealed
today that he had lunch yesterday here
at the White House with the leadership
of the NRA Wayne LaPierre and Chris Cox
a spokesperson for the NRA told Fox News
a few minutes ago that the leadership
has not dropped its opposition to
raising the minimum age to buy our rifle
nor will it Brett some breaking news
John just confirmed about hope Hicks
yeah we learned just a little while ago
Brett that another member of the
president's inner circle hope Hicks will
be paying a visit to the House
Intelligence Committee she is the
communications director here of course
she was his spokesperson and
communications director all through the
campaign she'll be visiting the house
permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence tomorrow morning right okay
John thank you more on that with
Catherine Harridge bit later